[Applaudissements]
nous on a invité ce soir est un grand
spécialiste de l'afrique il a été le
fondateur de l'est du continent il
publie ce livre africa france quand les
dirigeants africains deviennent les
maîtres du jeu aux éditions pluriel
bonsoir et bienvenue en tongs laser
bonsoir on va évidemment s'intéresser en
détail à votre nid d'abord une question
d'actualité avec le voyage tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui d' emmanuel macron
au maroc alors contrairement à ses
prédécesseurs
ce n'est pas en algérie que le nouveau
président a décidé d'aller en premier
bien sûr candidats il avait été en
algérie mais il ya d'abord choisi en
tant que président aller au maroc s'est
jamais anodin de choisir entre les
différents pays qu'est ce qu'on en pense
et c'est une rupture avec les
prédécesseurs n'ont oui enfin c'est une
p c'est une rupture mais en même temps
tout ça était bord mais ça veut dire
quand il est allé récemment à gao
rencontrer les troupes françaises il
avait téléphoné au président abdelaziz
bouteflika
jean yves le drian qui aussi qui par
l'ancien ministre la défense est allée
en même temps à alger a annoncé que le
président d alger mais c'est certain que
le maroc en particulier sur le plan
diplomatique le mix sur le plan de tout
ce qui se passe dans toute cette zone
sahélo saharienne c'est vrai que le
maroc c'est un c'est extrêmement
important comme relais videmment de la
france en afrique alors que l'algérie
ces dernières années étaient extrêmement
en retrait et puis a par contre ça
plutôt lent domaine militaire et
sécuritaire c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours
des problèmes avec l'algérie ses joueurs
extrêmement sensible et là on a vu
d'ailleurs c'est une visite c'est
incroyable ce qui est justement fait des
visites importantes après des visites
privées et personnelles
et là il démarre plutôt par une visite
personnelle uniquement avec brigitte
macron quasiment et quand on connaît le
maroc
on sait que c'est celle à la politique
un peu de la gazelle et de les relations
personnelles compte énormément donc là
c'est vrai que pour le roi du maroc pour
m6 est énorme
quelles relations sont selon-vous
entretien maintenant le président macron
avec ces pays du maghreb
évidemment on a retenu la phrase qu'il
avait prononcée en algérie en tant que
candidat qui a fait
beaucoup beaucoup parler les crimes
contre l'humanité mais lui quelle vision
il a des relations de la france avec ces
pays là du pourtour méditerranéen
je pense qu'il ya une prise de
conscience de l'importance de l'ensemble
de ces pays du pourtour méditerranéen
il ya une vraie conscience que la france
ne peut pas absolument pas continuer à
voir que l'opération barkan ses 4000
soldats dans une zone de 5 millions de
kilomètres carrés qui s'est complètement
c'est mission impossible maintenant tout
le monde le sait et c'est vrai que sans
en particulier l'algérie parce que
l'algérie qui est normalement quelqu'un
quand même qu'à la tutelle d accord
quand même des accords d'alger avec le
mali et finalement on voit que dans
toute cette région ce qui prime c'est
quand même le commerce en tous genres et
les trafics en tous genres mais on voit
que finalement les algériens est chez
eux sont très réticents ils ont accepté
quand même ce qu'ils appellent que la
france soit présente militairement dans
leur profondeur stratégique
c'est quand même assez nouveau pour les
algériens mais en même temps on sent
bien que ma qu'on veut mettre mêmes
macron le président veut mettre tous ces
pays au pied du mur en disant écoutez
nous on veut bien vous aider mais c'est
pas à la france pas continue à être le
gendarme comme ça de la fri dans cette
région il faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités non seulement le
gouvernement malien mais il a tiré un
message vis-à-vis des algériens parce
que tout le monde sait que les algériens
vis-à-vis un certain nombre de sièges
déjà dit c'est quand même l'algérie qu'à
exporter dans les pays voisins de al
qaïda du maghreb islamique le gia et c
est donc on voit que les un certain
nombre d'algériens ils regardent
ailleurs
il est sain peut faire ils n'ont pas
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait vraiment une
autonomie finalement ils ont pas
vraiment intérêt à ce que ça aille bien
au mali parce que si finalement le nord
du mali à une décentralisation une
autonomie qui sait si demain pas selon
d'algériens du site de l'algérie ve
ils vont pas dire à mannus aussi on veut
une large décentralisation donc
franchement les algériens on s'emm
choisir plutôt un statu quo c'est vrai
que les mains avec les marocains du fait
de la sphère du sahara occidental
ça reste difficile pour la france de
jouer entre ces deux grands partenaires
mais on sent qu'il ya une volonté d'
emmanuel macron de faire une sorte de
par frag mathis et de palais chez de pas
laisser les choses en l'état
ce qui serait bien c'est pour ça que
c'est le titre africa france que si les
occuper pas et s'occupa de l'afrique
après il va s'occuper de la faune l'un
des dossiers sur lequel tous ces pays
évidemment sont en relation étroite avec
la france et la lutte contre le
terrorisme il ya un pays qui inquiètent
et vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
jean yves le drian ministre des affaires
étrangères quittent actuellement en
algérie il est beaucoup question dans
ces discussions dit on de la libye la
libye où il ya des poches de résistance
vraiment de l'état islamique et on peut
rappeler que pour lens
l'attentât de manchester et bien ça a
été préparée semble-t-il depuis la libye
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment ça
fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas parlé est
ce que il y à une sorte de transhumance
j'allais dire des jihadistes depuis le
terrain moyen orientale vers la libye ça
je sais pas au niveau je pense spéciale
du théorie s'il ya une transhumance
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya
une responsabilité française vis-à-vis
de la libye
c'est quand même la france qui est
intervenir dans une sorte d' invincible
armada franco britannique en 2011
intervenue une façon très rapide sous
nicolas sarkozy
alors que l'union africaine ensemble de
pays était hostile à cette intervention
française qui est une intervention
aérienne
et finalement comme il dit comme le
disent les chefs d'état ça veut dire il
n'y a pas eu vraiment de suivi et
finalement ça a été ça a été alors qu'il
y avait une sorte de stabilité dans la
région de caen el-kadhafi quoi qu'on
pense de de lui comme dictateur mais il
acquit j'assurais il faisait un peu les
fans mois des pays de la région il avait
un certain nombre de jeunes qui était en
son temps dans son armée et puis avec le
grand frère algérien lui qui faisait la
sécurité donc certes cette région il ya
une sorte de 2 c'était quand même
peut-être instable mais au moins il y
avait quand même il n'y avait pas le
tous les armements qui sont quittés
quand même l'armurerie assez ouvert donc
tout le monde s'est servi jusqu'au
nigeria fait en ce moment de trouver la
salle a foncé syrie essayent de trouver
une solution mais c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce qu'il ya l'egypte via le
qatar il ya des add énormément d'acteurs
extérieurs étaient maintenant tout le
monde sait que c'est pas de l'extérieur
qu'on peut voir à faire le bonheur des
gens la bonne heure d'époque régler tout
ça mais abattre les phoques justement
est ce titre antoine glaser africa
france alors on va rappeler évidemment
qu'on avait l'habitude pour décrire les
relations entre la france et l'afrique
de parler de la françafrique alors
pourquoi africa france ce que selon vous
eh bien il ya intérêt des dirigeants
africains et intérêts ce qu'on croit
encore qu'il y a la françafrique
absolument ça veut dire is lucky penser
souvent d'ailleurs ils disent qu'ils
sont victimes de la françafrique la
françafrique c'est quelque chose de
particulier mais c'était une période
historique donnée de 1960 jusqu'à la
chute du mur de berlin en 1990 et on a
l'impression que la france enfin sauf
les spécialistes n'ont pas vu qu'ils ont
pensé que la chute du mur de berlin ça
se passe uniquement dans les pays de
l'est à berlin et ça concernait que
l'allemagne
ils n'ont pas compris que dans cette
région du monde les anciennes colonies
françaises qui ont acquis leur
indépendance en 1960 la france est resté
vraiment s'appelle de dépendance dans
l'interdépendance ça veut dire c'est une
région où vous aviez un des pays comme
la côte d'ivoire à abidjan vous aviez
cinquante mille français qu'ils aient
tourné le pays
et c'était une chasse gardée française
il y avait un système intégré politique
militaire financier
à l'époque on disait qu'ils avaient pas
un criquet qui stridulent est sans que
jacques foccart soit au courant donc
c'était un système intégré ces systèmes
politiques militaires financier s'est
intégré en plus la france avait des
ressources en uranium en pétrole avec
avec des pays verrouillé
en échange elle assurer la sécurité de
ses chefs d'état et ses chefs d'états le
disent part ils jouent toujours ceux qui
sont voilà c'est la france qui fait tout
mais ils ont le monde entier ils sont
dans la monde entier
et absolument ils ont monde entier si
vous allez même des pays qui est comme
la côte d'ivoire qui est quand même le
village gaulois de la france en afrique
vous avez la corée du sud les rues vous
avez des allemands aussi saïd ali
propres partenaires de la france qui ont
lieu qui lui ont laissé en contrepartie
d'être le gendarme de l'afrique qui ont
laissé les parts de marché à 50 60 %
quand il y avait un problème une
entreprise française
passez y avaient leurs basses hors de
france il passe un coup de fil aux
vieilles ou fouette et il avait le
contrat et on a l'impression que la
france n'a pas vu cette afrique changé
elle ad'autant ou moins vu cette afrique
changé c'est un peu l'arrogance
française un cas là c'était le titre de
votre but c'est d'en voir c'était c'est
pas un trait de caractère
seulement c'est surtout que la france a
exporté sur ce continent
non seulement sa langue mais son code
napoléonien elle a exporté toute sa
culture et à négliger totalement la
frite des africains cela frise africain
est en train d'émerger maintenant mais
la france le vois mal et le perçoit m'a
autant que les airs les dirigeants
français on les entend on les reçoit il
nous répète à l'envi que l'afrique c'est
l'avenir notre avenir ce tracé des beta
est ce qu'ils ont raté le train on a
parlé tout à l'heure de la sécurité est
ce qu'ils pensent trop l'afrique via la
sécurité et ils oublient à l'autre
l'autre pilier le développement le
codéveloppement a absolument absolument
mais il toujours que la présence de
l'armée française sert de cache misère
finalement une présence française
globalement en déshérence et il ya
vraiment un certain nombre de lait tous
les jeunes africains maintenant les ans
le quand ils en ont marre de cogner à la
porte des consulats de france
ils vont dans le monde entier d'ailleurs
il bombe de plus en plus haut au maroc
justement maintenant qu'à créer un
certain nombre d'écoles et donc on voit
bien que il ya une espèce que la france
pendant des années des années
naïm et que des africains qui lui
ressemblait ça veut dire c'est l'école
d'abord démissionnaire hans e toutes les
écoles et tous et des africains qui leur
semblait avec ce paternalisme que ne
supporte plus les africains aient eu
maintenant c'est l'afrique monde ça veut
dire où ils ont le monde entier et pas
simplement les dirigeants mais aussi les
sociétés civiles africaines qui commence
à bouger et qui ont des soutiens en
dehors de la france
ils ont plus qu on appelle l'esprit tour
eiffel qui avaient leurs
appareil mais on comprend parfaitement
évidemment votre à ce que ce que vous
dites intéressées mais en même temps
quand y ait eu un problème vous avez
parlé du mali tout est là qui est arrivé
quelle a été la seule force de
projection qui est venue quand même pour
aider sur place
la fractionnement mais c'est une c'est
bien c'est bien dans un espace très
courtes étaient atteints venu à
l'ancienne opération serval
c'était très bien mais quand vous avez
maintenant l'opération avec l'opération
barkan
on voit que la france a tendance à
s'enliser on voit qu emmanuel macron
demande aux allemands de payer pas
simplement maintenant et les soldats
allemands maintenant dans la mission des
nations unies au mali
mais en fait il veut absolument est
archi il veut vraiment que ce soit les
nations unies qui prennent en charge des
amériques à la semaine dernière on dit
aux français on veut pas voter une
résolution ils sont très réticents mais
pourquoi parce que pendant que la france
la sécurité en afrique les autres iphone
business les autres qui font le business
j'ai dix bombes à la france veut
continuer à faire ainsi curité très bien
puis les larmes et français ça se
comprend aussi si vous êtes militaires
français mais un vote job c'est aussi de
de faire la guerre et c'est donc pour
l'armée française c'était extrêmement
important
on a bien vu comment françois hollande
quand il a vu que ça allait mal en
centrafrique il a retiré l'opération
sans gari stefan trafic pour rester pour
dire finalement la france n'est plus le
gendarme de l'afrique à l'ancienne dans
ces pays pour soutenir des dictateurs
aller là pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et ça va de bamako jusque
jusqu'en france
donc c'est un c'est un discours qui a
évolué mais la réalité c'est que le
terrain c'est les problèmes d'éducation
de santé
c'est tout je veux dire si les et si
l'appui de société je veux dire c'est le
terreau général est alors qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour retisser ce
lien par qui ça doit passer texte doit
plus passer par les diplomates les
dirigeants c'est lui qui ira à nous on a
bien connu de révolution en france via
les civiles africaines qui sont
empreints kiki ça bouge énormément en
afrique vous avez des intellectuels
africains qui sont réunis récemment à
dakar et qui sont beaucoup plus qu'ils
veulent et développement endogène
réfléchi et réfléchir en tant
qu'africain à l'avenir des africains
arrêtés toujours il ne rejette pas tout
ce qui arrive de l'extérieur mais ça ne
pourra venir que du continent africain
et de même mais bon une question qui va
toujours
l'intéressé antoine glaser pourquoi ces
sociétés civiles africaines que vous
décrivez en plaine et ébullition
révolution pourquoi ne font-elles pas
justement la révolution entre guillemets
oui il ya eu elles le font mais vous
avez dans un sens vous avez ce qui se
passe actuellement c'est que vous avez
les légendes et les autocrates qui
veulent rester au pouvoir dix vingt ans
trente ans au bout d'un moment il se
faire il sera enfin avec la famille le
clan le premier cercle des cousins des
neveux et des et en élargissant un petit
peu aussi au clan et à l'ethnie est très
souvent les anciens compagnons route
ces cartes et puis ses compagnons route
c'est un moment donné et ses compagnons
passe dans l'opposition ils sont
soutenus par les sociétés civiles
africaines
c'est arrivé quand le président
abdoulaye wade a essayé de mettre son
fils karim wade pouvoir au sénégal c'est
arrivé au burkina faso quand même qui
était l'homme qui était protégé par les
militaires français parce que il y avait
ils avaient quand même couvert toutes
les turpitudes dans la région de l'armée
françaises et des français c'était le
président blaise compaore du burkina
faso c'est vous avez le ballet citoyens
qu'à soutenir roch kaboré un ancien
compagnon ou de blaise comparé vous avez
macky sall actuels présents du sénégal
qui à l'ancien qui étaient dans le même
parti le pds que abdoulaye wade ont
changé notre logiciel finalement repris
en danger de leur attention parce que
c'est chez moi je suis rien moi je suis
un petit blanc des bords de seine
mais c'est simplement de faire
comprendre qu'ils sont toujours en train
de dire oui faut nous aider machin etc
mais en même temps en franchement ils
ont le monde entier et vous allez voir
ça bouge énormément alors il ya des
endroits c'est comme cv enfants les
galeries de scop
vous avez des endroits qui sont vraiment
j'avais beaucoup de conflits et tout est
des endroits où il ya un fort
développement
vous avez des groupes comme orange qui
ont plus d'abonnés maintenant dans des
pays comme l'égypte qu'en france ça
bougeait énormément ça veut dire vous
avez bien sûr des classes moyennes c'est
horrible à dire mais quand l'afrique va
passer de 1 à 2 milliard d'habitants
vous aurez bien évidemment vous avez
encore 500 millions de pauvres des gens
extrêmement pauvre mais il ya toujours
une classe moyenne 300 millions et
autres et franchement quand les français
assurent la sécurité des zones libres on
fait du business et c'est pour ça que
vous dites
africa france est plus là
ce afrique c'est d'abord l'afrique et il
faudrait penser à donc à changer ce
logiciel merci antoine glaser